hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
irgendein video ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt gut ich war vorgestern mal wieder
beim viele von euch kennen vielleicht
schon der war auch schon zweimal in
meinen videos dabei oder halt aus der
fernsehsendung retouren profis auf rtl
wo ich auch mal mitgemacht habe und das
ist der typ der die ganzen retouren und
irgendwelche barren und alles mögliche
weiterverkauf wo meine zu mir alex du
musst mal wieder vorbeikommen ich habe
einiges neues und das hat mich natürlich
sehr gefreut und ich bin mal hingefahren
und ich schauen wir uns ganz kurz mal an
also leute wir sind immer noch bei monde
hat mir jetzt noch was alles an gedreht
angedreht was ist denn das sind extra
okay von
muss selbst verraten gehört ist von
karstadt die gibt es ja nicht mehr
deswegen sehr interessant interessant
deshalb wind behalte ich mal gespannt ob
du sowas nicht verkaufen kannst aber du
machst das schon will also leute ich hab
gehört dass sind noch ein paar karstadt
ja ich würde nicht sagen retouren
sondern einfach auflösungs ware weil die
gibt's halt nicht mehr und ich bin mal
gespannt ob sich das lohnt bis jetzt
gleich wo hier muss ich doch gut
verhandeln weil hier kann ich jetzt
sagen ob man weiß genau was ist wenn
intelligenz und die waren irgendwann
paletten dabei immer glück bringen
könnte sich das abgeben von karstadt
krise
also ihr habt gehört und gesehen heute
geht es um karstadt auflösung insolvenz
retouren wahre ich habe um ehrlich zu
sein keine art viele von euch haben es
wahrscheinlich mitbekommen ich musste
mir gerade noch mal die genaue story
dazu durchlesen aber diese ganzen großen
karstadt filialen wie sie überall in
deutschland verteilt waren gibt es so
nicht mehr die sind zwar zwei jahren ca
pleite gegangen weil man vielleicht dazu
sagen muss dass karstadt bereits seit
2010 mit der insolvenz gekämpft hat dem
jahr 2016 2017 haben es aber nochmal
geschafft schwarze zahlen zu schreiben
bis es seien ja trotz vor kroner wäre es
um einig gewesen komplett in die brüche
ging die karstadt filiale in frankfurt
auf der zeil wurde geschlossen hier bei
uns in der nähe wurde auch einer
geschlossenen es gibt aber weiterhin
bestehen die galeria karstadt kaufhof
gmbh welche diese ganzen galeria
karstadt filialen betreibt aber es gibt
halt nicht mehr karstadt einzeln und
galeria einzeln sondern nur noch
zusammen so ganz durchblicken tue ich da
auch nicht aber ist mir egal hauptsache
das wird spannend ich bin ich immer ein
auf den paketen liegt gekauft habt ist
eigentlich immer nur die rede von
karstadt bis auf eine ausnahme da ist ja
noch die rede von einem wahren abgabe an
vermarkter und dann tritt hier die
galeria karstadt kaufhof gruppe auf ich
will es einmal also als auflösungs ware
bezeichnen und wir schauen jetzt mal
genauer an sind textilien schuhe und so
aber können sie schon interessant werden
let's golf staaten war ein okay leute
würde ich sagen wir lieber gar nicht
lange daten direkt ich muss sagen eines
jahre habe ich noch gemerkt und zwar rät
hier war es gleich ob das klappt schon
bei der einbindung gesehen waren
umlagerungen keine ahnung wahrscheinlich
wird es dann von einem karstadt der
pleite gegangen ist in den nächsten
galeria kaskada ich habe keine ahnung
hoffen wir einfach mal dass es sich
lohnt und eine sache die ich noch sagen
muss weil es sicherlich viele
interessiert ich habe vor karton nur 100
euro bezahlt also das flicken der sehr
fairer preis und mosaic oft viel mehr
verkaufen aber ja keine ahnung ich mach
das jetzt auch nicht um damit möglichst
viel geld zu verdienen sondern um euch
einfach nur zu zeigen was da drin ist
weil es mich selber interessiert und
auch nur textilien loswerden ist sowieso
super schwer für mich also keine ahnung
wenn ich irgendwas davon
reebok schuhe wenn ihr irgendwas davon
gebrauchen können bleibt mir gerne in
seoul ist okay wir starten direkt mal
rein es sieht aus wie ein bisschen chaos
aber da kann man nichts gegen machen das
hier ist das erste ps das schöne ist wir
haben direkt preise mit 79 95 hat es mal
gekostet jetzt kostet nur noch 49 99 die
frage ist halt aus welchem jahr das ist
ne marke reckmann kenne ich gar nicht 50
euro für so ein ding das macht auch gute
qualität auf jeden fall neubert ich okay
die sehe ich jetzt hier online für rund
20 euro oder so oder vielleicht auch ein
bisschen kommt drauf an also von bis was
man ja auch dazu sagen muss karstadt
hatte glaube ich immer ich war jetzt
nicht so aber da gab es sachen die waren
billig und es gab auch teurere marken
und immer natürlich mehrere etagen ich
habe jetzt bei rec man gesehen dass
wurde sicherlich auch bei karstadt
verkauft aber auch kaufhäuser oder luxus
kaufhäuser wie breuninger vertreiben da
immer davon aus dass das jetzt halt
einfach nicht die neueste kollektion ist
aber das trinken haben wir dann hier
noch mal und ich denke mal vielleicht
auch noch mal um noch mal und noch mal
und ist das jetzt hier andere farbe aber
ebenfalls redman das kostet jetzt nur
noch 59 99 so gar keine ahnung ich muss
genau dieses modell ist einmal finden
weil es wäre nice wenn ich euch ja so
ein bisschen die preise mit 1 werden
kann und wir dann immer höher gehen und
schauen einfach mal wie es der
gesamtwertung den wahren der hier drin
ist also die sachen aus den neuesten
kollektionen hier kosten auf jeden fall
auch alle so 70 80 euro 150 euro sogar
also das ist schon eine vernünftige
marke deswegen würde ich sagen wir
rechnen die preise hier dran stehen auch
wenn es rabatte sind einfach mal hoch
und schauen was am ende bei rumkommen
ich will mir jetzt schon sicher das wird
einiges weil wer hätte es gedacht wir
haben hier nochmal reckmann und nochmal
reckmann kann ich mittlerweile schon
sagen reckmann geht mir ziemlich auf ein
segment weil vielleicht wäre auch mal
was anderes ganz nahe dass mit raten
jetzt kommen was neu ist das hier ist
selected homme ok schiffs oder gar kein
preis dran aber das ist so ein winter
pulli hat ja auch gesagt da sind sachen
aus der winterkollektion dabei weiß er
noch nicht welche winterkollektionen ist
das wahrscheinlich halt nicht so die
neueste winterkollektion wenn sich
jemand mit mode auskennt und mir sagen
kann von welcher kollektion das ist hier
so leichte traum dort nicht sofort
kostet 59 euro 99 würde das jetzt gerne
einmal für euch anziehen aber ich meine
wir haben 33 grad draußen und hier drin
sind 37 grad abkommen egal da muss ich
jetzt durch wir wollen ja sehen ob das
hier neiße sachen sind also für den
winter viel verpasst mit perfect
normalerweise drei big l das ist jetzt
xl aber warum eigentlich die leute jetzt
bin ich gespannt wir machen wir einfach
mal weiter mit neuen bugatti european
ducati ist eine marke die kenne ich auf
jeden fall die schule von den feiere ich
jetzt nicht so kollege von mir hat die
nico heißt der ja so sind die aus
regiert wie kuckuck macht wenn du willst
kannst du die haben größe haben wir
jetzt eine größe 43 sogar das ist genau
meine größe die werde ich jetzt gleich
mal anprobieren und die kosten 69 eur 99
jahre gatti schuhe wirklich absolut
neuwertig hier ist ja gar nichts dran
ist dass jetzt auch noch das land
irgendeinem teil hier aufgefallen
deswegen wirklich alles neuwertige ware
das ist sofern das gefällt mir auch ich
ziehe schon mal eben an wie ok die
schuhe sind eigentlich ganz nice aus
dann sollten wir kleine montag
[Musik]
diese habe ich diesen pulli noch anhält
dann haben wir hier noch check-in john
auch schön probiere ich auch mal eben an
sega mega das behalte ich wohl mal das
steht mir doch oder leute seien wir
ehrlich das ist doch nicht verkehrt 32
eur 99 jahren hier vorstellen das ist es
die schuhe haben wir schon angeschaut
jetzt habe ich hier noch mehr schuhe und
zwar reebok skyline terry fox hatte ich
früher sehr viel aber mal zusammen rein
vielleicht sind das ja richtig nice
sowie blogs nicht jedenfalls beiden kann
nein das sind frauen schuhe
joggingschuhe alter aber auch mit top
qualität hier leute schaut mal man muss
ja auch sagen karstadt hat noch immer
diese sport etage dann auch so eine
laufbahn war wo man sich so ja wo man
messen konnte wie schnell man ist daran
kann ich mich noch erinnern was kosten
die schau mal kurzhaar 35 euro nur okay
das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht aber
naja was willst du machen trotzdem enorm
stecken so war das gleiche oberteil in
einer anderen farbe wahrscheinlich
ebenfalls 39 99 also der wert ist schon
gigantisch und das sind auf jeden fall
weit über 1000 euro hier an war mehr
drin und dann hier noch ein bisschen
reckmann 59 99 für mich aber sicher
einem anderen pakets nur noch mal andere
sachen das hier ist jetzt wieder
reckmann wir machen das jetzt mal im
schnelldurchlauf der kinder uns noch
macht ebenfalls 39 99 ist echt wahr
machen sie doch einfach aus allen mensch
was natürlich noch meister gewesen wäre
wäre wenn das komplette mich wahre von
kaufland gewesen wäre ja wie oft habe
ich jetzt wäre in einem satz verwehrt
weil die hatten ja nicht nur textilien
sondern auch irgendwie computerspiele
glaubt man konnte sogar eine playstation
kaufen lass mich raten reckmann reckmann
49 99 vielleicht gibt es ja unter euch
so einen text jedem große center der das
alles auf einmal mitnimmt weil ich weiß
wirklich nicht was ich mit diesem ganzen
zeug machen soll xxl jack and jones ok
den kennen wir schon haben wir den hier
nochmal 39 99 dollar denn hier ist
electronics 59 99 regen hier kenne ich
noch nicht aber er ist auch von redmond
der pulli ist eigentlich auch nicht
verkehrt den finde ich ohne scheiß echt
ganz schön 79 95 pullover und alltäglich
auch also die qualität von redmond die
überzeugt mich jack jones und nochmals
agenten und noch mal jacksons dann ist
das erste paket auch leider schon leer
tut mir leid aber wir haben ja noch eins
und das wird sicherlich auch ich war
hier heute seid ihr bereit 12
wer hat's gesehen oho wir haben hier als
erstes einfach wenn's um mein gott es
adidas und nike schuhe alleine diese
schuhe sind ja selbst schon viel viel
mehr wert als ein events waren früher
auf jeden fall meine lieblingsschuhe
davon hatte ich einige wenn ich jetzt
mal gespannt größe 42 für männer sogar
das ist alter leute gebt euch das ist
einfach dieser klassische weiß nicht was
hat er früher gekostet oder was kosten
die 80 90 euro geil er schlüpfe ich mal
rein passt nicht so ganz
da passe ich nicht rein schade na ja
trotzdem schon mal will wenn es einfach
so fahren und dann haben wir hier noch
adidas schuhe kommen ich will es ihr
könnt das erste gucken hier wird schön
oh ja genau meine farbe adidas running
schuss für damen oder sportschuhe so zu
tun also genauso sahen eigentlich die
schuhe aus von ihrem zweiten mädchen mit
dem ich früher sportunterricht hatte ja
das von gut hin passt nur 25 euro ich
wusste gar nicht dass frauen sportschuhe
so günstig sind oder war das doch nicht
so oder also das na ja dann haben wir
hier jetzt noch nike schuhe let's go
alter was sind das denn für diesen teil
junge schuhgröße 40 oder was auch
komplett neue natürlich ja karton
gefällt mir auf jeden fall schon mal
besser vielleicht sind das ja wirklich
so seltene schuhe auf obwohl das ist
glaube ich nicht bei karstadt neigt wie
er wohl größte 47 55 kosten 75 europa
trotzdem nicht verkehrt und es geht
weiter mit selected homme den kennen wir
schon 59
ich sehe schon wieder reckmann leute es
tut mir leid was ist das denn für
unterwäsche und ski unterwäsche sollte
man nicht unterschätzen die ist nämlich
manchmal echt teuer wobei hier gar keine
marke bei steht deswegen alter ego dann
haben wir hier noch mal auf was neues
cappuccino italia marke kenne ich gar
nicht ich guck mal da 28 euro höher
nicht so dolle das wurde aber schon
benutzt ja okay jetzt habe ich nochmal
termotek das ist eine hose für welche
mit ganz langen beinen doch marek man
den kennen wir schon den hier kennen wir
aus schauen also wir haben bestimmt ohne
schein 15 bis 20 von diesem rating an
also so gesehen allein schon mal 750
euro reckmann 69 99 wieder redman
deutsche sorry ich mache jetzt einfach
kurz und schmerzlos weil irgendwie macht
es ja sonst auch keinen sinn cappuccino
sagt jack jones 1999 das hier ist noch
mal was andere von taylor ist natürlich
auch eine marke die habe ich früher mal
als ich so ein kleiner putsch war wurde
auch reduziert auf 93 sich 990 hier
haben wir noch was für die ladies und
hier sollen das ist das kleid sehr gut
das kann ich erst so schlecht anziehen
muss ich dann auch einfach einsehen dass
mir so etwas nicht steht auch wenn ich
natürlich das gerne bisschen betonen
würde hierfür instagram sowas haben wir
dann hier noch das mir geraten reckmann
der wievielte redman ist dass leute ich
bin mal gespannt was am ende hier unten
steht aber es wird bestimmt 2000 euro
seien bragman 49 99 cappuccino
ich hoffe reckmann ware ist gefragt ist
ja auf jeden fall gut und hier am kino
und tom tailor und ja da war es dann im
großen und ganzen werde es mich
natürlich ein bisschen mehr gefreut wenn
dann noch mehr abwechslung wird aber das
kann man natürlich vorher nie wissen
trotzdem glaube ich dass es ein cooles
video war und ihr könnt ihr hier sehen
da ist schon einiges an ware drin
gewesen also hier auf jeden fall viel
gespieltem ich habe natürlich auch noch
andere waren mitgenommen ja mal gespannt
das wird sich johnston stehen dann für
zuschauer und steckt auf jeden fall die
letzte news abgeschaut beim einem
anderen kanal vorbei alexa ich denke da
gibt es jeden tag ein video um wir sehen
uns haut rein das
radeln